Brittney's in Houston Texas welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Brittany hi thank
you so much for taking my call sure
what's up so we're in babies up to me
and my husband he's 31 I'm 30 and we
just moved from Wyoming in pen and then
Pennsylvania into Texas so we're
currently trying to sell our house but
outside of the house were about ninety
eight thousand dollars in debt between
our car loans and our credit card debts
and so we're renting our house while
we're trying to sell but we're kind of
drowning in our budget so we look at
trying to sell our card but we're upside
down on them and so we're not sure how
to sell our cars exactly hmm so in order
to try to get out of out of the initial
loan car number one so car number one is
$33,000 what's it worth well Kelly Blue
Book says you know it's around 28 but
when we went in he said the most he
could offer is 26 that would be a dealer
well dealers don't pay retail for cars
they pay wholesale for cars because they
resell them at retail so it's probably
worth about 28 if you put it on
Craigslist okay what's the second car
oh don't wash the second car I'm
actually not sure exactly because that
really wasn't on the table for my
husband but it was like you know
somewhere between the same range so
maybe like 35 okay I'm sorry
it's not on the table for your husband
what the crap does that mean you guys
are starving to that allowance from work
what okay he gets an allowance for work
for his truck I was so low he's broke I
understand getting an allowance from
work does not make owning a car you
can't afford work right my car is
650 dollars a month and hisses you know
a little bit over that so like seven
what is your cultural mental oh yeah
so take-home we we came up with like
about seventy thousand a year so your
gross is about ninety and your cars are
both absolutely asinine insane they both
need to be sold so it goes on the table
a grown-up will look at this and say you
cannot afford these cars so your
husband's gonna have to be a grown-up
okay this is ridiculous I mean now who
do you owe the money to on these cars so
one is a Lending Tree is that is that
correct I don't think there is any
longer in business and the other one I'm
not sure of either but their banks I'm
pretty sure about that okay is your
credit has it survived this debacle mine
probably hasn't but I think his has I
think his is pretty different we're not
like delinquent on any payments or
anything but I mean we're doing that
every dollar budget and we don't your
course so we're about two weeks into
your course you're going to need to look
you're gonna need to talk to a credit
union or small local bank about getting
a small unsecured loan to get both of
these cars sold and you're both are
going to have to get in some much much
less expensive cars like $5,000 cars and
get this mess cleaned up because these
cars are destroying your life we have
our house that that we're trying to sell
yeah the house is not the issue
I'm partners as well yeah okay the house
is not the issue these cars are there as
a percentage of your income their
insanity I'm serious
you are going you're heading towards the
wall you're gonna hit the wall your life
is gonna disintegrate and you're never
gonna know what happened if you don't
get rid of these cars they're really
really really a problem I hope I've not
been unclear because I really want to
help you guys but I don't
if I can help your husband sounds like
he's a hard head right now so I've been
a hard head to the problem of being a
hard head is it cause you hit the wall
that much harder if you don't wake up
and so the stuff is ridiculous they're
out of control you made really really
bad decisions with these cars the good
news is you can undo the decision you
can have to amputate this crap out of
your life so you can get your life back
think about what if you had no car
payments just hum just think about that
if you just can swallow that into your
spirit right now I mean you guys have
probably fourteen hundred fifteen
hundred dollars in car payments I mean
that's just nuts there's no other way to
describe it so I'm not picking on you
I'm trying to make sure I get through to
my old heart head over there so
everything gets back on the table
because everything's gonna get on the
table and it's gonna get off the table
because we're selling them if you don't
do that
I predict years of problems in your
future and I'm right